[Music]
welcome to Koch news bearing the most
important news and informations from
Hollywood and the world of movies this
time the teaser trailers for two Star
Wars series have been leaked cyberpunk
2077 will become a liveaction series and
the half-finished Daredevil series will
completely start over we also have news
on the second season of one piece a
prequel to Oceans 11 starring Margot
Robbie and Ryan Gosling and much more
here are the
details are Barbie and Ken up to no good
after the mega success Barbie Margot
Robbie and Ryan goling are returning to
the camera handin hand to starring a new
spin-off of the popular Oceans 11 series
released in 2001 and starring George
Clooney Brad Pit Matt Damon and Julia
Roberts the Rogue comedy Oceans 11 was
not only a financial success but also
enjoys cult status now over the years
three more films followed including a
female version starring Sandra bulck
Kate Blanchet and Anne Hathaway since
the series continues to enjoy great
popularity Warner Brothers is now
planning a prequel to Oceans 11
precisely with Margot Robbie and Ryan
Gosling Josie mamera who will produce
the prequel already expressed his
anticipation about the casting of the
two superstars in an interview with
variety preferably he said they would
like to immediately take on a series of
Productions in which Gosling and Robbie
would be involved according to initial
information the story of the new oceans
film will be set in the 1960s and will
focus on a shipping magnet and his yacht
which will be targeted by the duo the
prequel is said to be inspired by the
films of Grandmaster Alfred Hitchcock
for example the classic To Catch a Thief
according to director Jay roach in an
interview with Associated Press the film
will be a mix between Love Story
adventure and Heist movie and will be a
great cinematic spectacle we'll continue
to keep an eye on the project Jim Lee
Curtis as Dr kha in the second season of
One Piece according to co- showrunner
Matt Owens at least who has already
spoken out positively about the
possibility of casting the actress the
first season of one piece was a
phenomenal success for Netflix in season
2 additionally to the already familiar
characters some new characters should be
joining the cast including Tony Chopper
and Dr kha according to initial
information a suitable actress already
seems to have been found for the latter
we're talking about Halloween star Jam
Lee Curtis in an interview with deadline
Matt Owens explained that they are
currently working on giving Jam Lee
Curtis the role the actress had shortly
before communicated to have absolute
interest in playing the character
whether or not the role will ultimately
go to her will depend on the current
course of the actor strike however Owens
has already announced that the
64-year-old actress will definitely be
cast in the project
somehow trailer leak at Disney next year
two new Star Wars projects in the form
of the Acolyte and skeleton crew should
be presented to us both of them already
aroused the interest of fans shortly
after their announcement the fact that
the first teaser trailers of both series
have now been leaked is likely to cause
a lot of trouble within the company the
videos have been C circulating the web
for several days and are being shared on
all social networks a few days later an
entry was made at the US copyright
office which revealed that Skeleton Crew
will be released in January of 2024 the
assumption that Disney is reacting to
the trailer leaks with this entry is
obvious Skeleton Crew is set shortly
after the fall of the Galactic Empire
and addresses a group of children who
experience a series of Adventures in
addition to Jalil white known to many as
Steve Urkel on the sitcom Family Matters
the show will also feature Jude Law in a
major role the acolyte on the other hand
is set 100 years before the events of
Star Wars episode 1 and will show us a
whole new side of the Sith several
prominent names have already been
confirmed for the project among others
Matrix star Kenne Moss bodies bodies
bodies actress amand L Stenberg and
Squid game Star Lee Jung Jay are
involved if you want to learn more about
the title feel free to check out our
series
preview the controversial game becomes a
live action show after The Witcher the
next implementation of a CD project Red
game is on the horizon cyberpunk 2077
the US Film Production Company Anonymous
content will be responsible for the
realization of the hype game this is an
independent producer that has already
released several celebrated titles such
as True Detective Mr Robot and the
revenue in a statement to the Press game
developers CD project red announced that
they are currently looking for a writer
to tell new stories from the world of
cyberpunk since the game came with an
impressive cast the question whether
actors like Idris Elba or Kiana Reeves
could also find a place in the series
arises since the project is currently
still in an early phase of development
no information about a cast or a
storyline of the cyberpunk 2077 series
is known yet last year cyberpunk Edge
runers an anime series for the game was
already released the 10 episodes are
currently available on
Netflix no good Prospect for Daredevil
Marvel is discarding the already shot
footage for the reboot Daredevil born
again and is said to begin a complete
restart this will also likely cause
further resentment among fans
Daredevil born again is without a doubt
one of the very big series projects that
are eagerly awaited by the crowds
however the production of the series
repeatedly got bad attention because of
producing issues as The Hollywood
Reporter now reports Kevin feige is said
to have looked at the already completed
material of the series during the actors
and writer strike his judgment the
series simply does not work in this form
as a result all the writers and
directors who were responsible for the
project were fired instead a new
creative team is currently being sought
to revive the superhero series from
scratch only individual scenes if any
from the previous work will be used for
the reboot these developments are likely
to ensure that a release of the series
will continuously be delayed currently
January 2025 is being targeted The
Hollywood Reporter also suspects that
the current events surrounding Daredevil
born again could also be related to
structural changes at Marvel the studio
has moved farther away from its
traditional way of working with Series
in ordered complete seasons instead of
pilot episodes with huge budgets
sometimes the projects were then shot
without even knowing whether they would
work out in the end as a reaction to
this Marvel is now planning to work
again more closely with show Runners and
executive producers for its own TV
division in order to ensure a better
quality of their projects viewers would
certainly be more than grateful for
that the legendary Duo returns 23 years
after the highly celebrated World War II
Epic Band of Brothers Steven Spielberg
and Tom Hanks are teaming up again to
present masters of the air another
series that is likely to follow the
tradition of its predecessors with the
2001 World War II series Band of
Brothers Steven Spielberg and Tom Hanks
may have undoubtedly written TV history
the impressive show which told the story
of an elite group of paratroopers during
World War II convinced with great and
detailed settings and arousing story six
Emmys were the result the sequel the
Pacific was convincing as well and one
another two Emmys with masters of the
air another sequel will follow next year
which will tell us the story of the
100th Bombadier group of the US Air
Force during World War II the storyline
of the show is based on the aonomus
novel by Donald L Miller and will this
time be directed by James Bond director
krie Jo G fukunaga produced by Steven
Spielberg and Tom Hanks the series
features a phenomenal cast with leading
roles played by Elvis star Austin Butler
and the Banshees of in airan actor Barry
kogan and Callum Turner of the Fantastic
Beast series in the course of announcing
the launch date Apple released a bunch
of first images that show us the cast of
the show among other things we see
Butler and kogan and a pilot's uniform
standing in front of an Air Force
fighter plane the miniseries will
premere on Apple TV Plus on January 26th
2024 and will hopefully build on the
quality of its forerunners we are
excited with heat director Michael man
may be responsible for one of the
greatest films of the 9s which still
enjoys great popularity almost 30 years
later now the director announced that a
sequel to the classic will be following
the rumor that Michael Mann is flirting
with the idea of a sequel to he has been
spooking through Hollywood for several
years now the director confirmed to
collider that the film will be on his
next project it'll be based on the novel
of the same name which he published
together with author Meg Garder during
the shooting of his new film Ferrari the
book picks up directly at the end of the
first part ands us the story of Al
Pacino's policeman Hannah who searches
for clues in the house of Robert Dao's
character mcau in the course of the
investigation macau's past is brought up
so he will also be playing a leading
role in the sequel since Heat 2 is a
mixture of Sequel and prequel mcau will
return in a younger form according to
rumors Adam Driver will take over the
role of the gangster and thus succeed
Robert dairo driver already started
man's new film Ferrari and seems to have
made an impression on the director who
will this time take over the role of
Hannah is not yet known a younger
version of Val Kilmer's character Chris
shures an important part of macau's gang
is also expected to appear in the film
when heat 2 will finally be released
remains to be seen for now Michael man's
biopic Ferrari which will be released in
the US on December 25th 20 23 is waiting
in the
wings that was a lot of news so we hope
you feel very well informed now for more
detailed information make sure to also
check out our newest Originals on the
Joker 2 and How to Train Your Dragon
liveaction remake and don't forget to
give us a thumbs up if you like our
videos what do you think about the
latest news let us know in the comments
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next
week
[Music]